in this video we'll be explaining all
demon moons in demon slayer we will talk
about their previous lives as humans as
well as the events of their new lives as
members of 12 kazuki we'll start with
the former lower rank 6 kyogai but in
the later parts of the video we'll be
covering much stronger and more
interesting demons kiogai also known as
drum demon is the primary antagonist in
the tsutsumi mansion arc he was a demon
formerly affiliated with the 12 kazuki's
lower ranks having held the position of
lower rank 6 while he was still a member
of the 12 kazuki kyogai slowly lost the
ability to eat humans he was visited by
muzan kibutsuji who removed his number
due to the drum demon having reached his
limit because of this kyogai obsessively
began his quest to rejoin the
organization at some point kyogai
captured kyoshi due to him possessing
rare blood and took him to the drum
house before he could eat him he was
attacked by two other demons who were
also after kiyoshi's rare blood
suffering an injury that dislodged the
drum from his back he passed by the room
tangido and teruku were in annoyed by
the presence of all the intruders in his
territory slapping the drum on his right
shoulder when the former attempted to
attack him which changed the orientation
of the room with the arrival of inosuke
the drum demon struck his right shoulder
again as tanjido and inosuke quarrelled
kyougai struck the drum on his stomach
twice each time launching a slashing
claw attack he then struck his shoulder
drums multiple times sending his
adversaries flying in a disorganized
mess as he stepped in the direction of
inosuke he along with everyone else were
transported into different rooms he
happened upon tanjiro in the course of
his wandering striking a drum to flip
the room upside down striking another to
initiate his claw attack along with a
slew of others to disorientate his
opponent memories from the past caused
kyogai to snap and initiated his rapid
drumming technique and sparking a
maelstrom of effects tanjiro evaded a
collection of manuscripts that fell from
a shelf on the ceiling which surprised
the former kizuki despite his continued
slash attacks and orientation changes to
the room kyoga's opponent continued to
close on him by using a certain water
breathing technique the former kizuki
was further surprised when tanjido
complimented his blood demon art before
decapitating him he asked the youth if
he really thought his techniques were
powerful which was confirmed but he was
told that eating humans was unforgivable
fading into oblivion kyoukai reflected
on how tanjido had seen the value in all
of his work tears running down his face
next demon moon on our list is rui rui
was a former lower rank five and a
member of the spider family that he
created who lived at natalmo mountain
many years ago gruy was born with a weak
frail and easily stressed human body
that even the very act of walking and
breathing was difficult for him to do
causing him to spend a majority of his
life trapped within his home being cared
for by his mother and father who despite
his frailty deeply loved and cherished
him one night rui was approached by
muzan kibutsuji who then offered to save
him and transform him into a demon now
possessing a strong body rui was finally
able to move freely for the first time
bringing joy and happiness to his
parents however this did not last as he
was now a demon rui needed to obtain
sustenance by eating humans which then
caused him to kill a man inside his home
his parents then tried to kill him but
rui killed them both instead in
self-defense due to repressing his
painful memories as a human rui
requested to muzan if he could create a
family for himself the latter then
allowed him and he began to gather
suitable family members who would each
take the role of his new parents and
siblings he then created the so-called
spider family during a natagumo mountain
arc rui engages in battle with tanjino
when tanjido attempted to strike aside a
thread with his water breathing his
sword breaks the moment it makes contact
with the thread rui continues with a
patient assault striking with his
threads which tanjiro continues to dodge
with some difficulty a large web
descends on tanjiro unable to dodge or
block the strike he is protected by
nizuko while tanjido tends to nizuko's
injuries the spider demon sister speaks
noting how nizuko emerged from her box
to protect tanjiro despite being a demon
rui takes interest in nizuko and demands
that tanjido hand her over to him
tanjido refuses but rui grabs nizuko
anyway tanjido uses his total
concentration water breathing to cut
rui's threats something he had been
unable to do up to that point due to a
potential threat brewery unleashes his
blood demon art in a moment of
desperation and near death tanjiro for
the first time ever in battle uses the
hinokami kagura and is able to slice
through rui's reinforced threads with
his new strength tanjido presses the
attack and is able to get the upper hand
against rui awakening mazuko helps her
brother unlocking and using her blood
demon art both burning rui his threads
an enhancing tangible sword to the point
he is able to behead rui rui reveals
himself to be alive having beheaded
himself to avoid tanjido's sword as roy
uses his blood demon art murderous eye
basket giu arrives and destroys the
technique water hashida soon with ease
decapitates lower moon since muzan
killed all of the remaining lower ranks
leaving only enmu alive we will jump
straight to enmu stay tuned because in a
few minutes we'll start explaining much
more interesting upper moon demons and
moon knew that he had been converted due
to muzan's whim and would only remember
him in passing so enmu did his best to
ascend to the position of lower rank 1.
after being the last remaining lower
moon alive when asked for his final
words enmu expresses joy at muzan
killing him personally and for the
suffering of humans and his fellow ranks
thanking his leader for leaving him
until last muzan then changes his mind
as he glances at him enmu was then
stabbed by a needle-like appendage in
the neck and given a generous amount of
muzan's blood with muzan telling him to
be useful to him by killing the demon
slayer core's hashira muzan promises
that if he kills the demon slayer with
hanafuda earrings tanjiro kamado and mu
will get even more blood and move that
devises a plan to put all demon slayers
and passengers aboard mugen train to
sleep later he stands upon the steam
engine remarking that dying while
dreaming is a blessing one of enmu's
hands speaks with the train's conductor
about the success of putting the demon
slayers to sleep and do the same to him
shortly after he turns as tanjido
approaches him greeting him and stating
that he showed him a pleasant dream but
could have made it a nightmare thanks to
tanjido and inosuka's joint effort they
managed to discover enmu's head and
subsequently behead him by completely
cutting off the train's top engine
compartment enmu in complete disbelief
at his failure begins to curse all the
demon slayers and the upper ranks due to
being inferior to them in power as his
body slowly disintegrates he attempts to
at least kill the weakened tanjido and
inosuke but only failed once more as his
body began to crumble faster now the
part you've all been waiting for let's
start explaining upper moon demons
there's a total of nine upper ranked
demons so we'll start with the number
nine kaigaku kagaku was a former demon
slayer and zenitsu's senior disciple
under the former thunder hashira jigoro
kuajima kaigaku was an orphan and a
thief who had to eat scraps and steal to
survive he was one of the orphans
gyomehimejima cared for at his temple
after he was caught by the other
children for stealing temple money he
was chased out at night and encountered
a demon which he then led into the
temple in exchange for having his life
spared kaigaku developed the belief that
strength and survival were the only
things worth respecting and was willing
to grovel and beg for his life if that's
what it took to survive eventually he
was taken in by jigoro along with
zenitsu learning thunder breathing he
became determined to become jigoro's
successor and the new thunder hashira
jigoro however insisted that both he and
zenitsu would become his successors
despite zanitsu's weakness and timid
nature during the hashida training arc
zenitu receives word that kaidaku had
become a demon and ajigoro committed
seppuku as atonement kaigaku had the
unfortunate luck of encountering
kokushibo and upon witnessing the
latter's immense power kneeled before
him and begged to become a demon as a
demon kaigaku had eaten many people and
became powerful enough to become the new
upper rank six of the twelve kuzuki
inside the infinity castle he encounters
zenitsu and the two engaging combat he's
ultimately beheaded by zenith's thunder
breathing kaigoku mockingly comments
that their master did favor zenitu more
for teaching him that form until zenith
admits that the technique was his own
making in order to fight alongside
kagaku as equals kaigaku notes that
zenith was going to die from severe
exhaustion only for him to be saved by
yushiro in the last seconds kaigaku's
head screams in anger as he
disintegrates
number 8. daki daki is the secondary
holder of the position of upper rank 6 a
position she shares with the primary
holder her older brother gyutaro she is
one of the primary antagonists in the
entertainment district arc daki was born
many years ago with the birth name of
ume in the entertainment district's area
her birth mother was a prostitute there
having given birth to her elder brother
a few years before when ume was born
their mother hated her due to her hair
color and eyes and would try to kill her
ume was primarily raised by her elder
brother until her early teen years when
her mother passed away from the disease
known as ume the same sickness she was
then named after growing up she was very
beautiful in her early teen years she
was finally chosen to work in one of the
entertainment district's high class
brothels ume began making a fortune by
attracting many suitors and customers to
the brothel due to her beauty at the
same time her elder brother began
working as her collector and would
collect money and debts owed to the
brothel however this all came to an end
when ume poked out the eye of a samurai
a customer of hers when he insulted her
brother while her brother was away
collecting debts in retaliation to this
she was tied burned alive and left to
die in a ditch she was then discovered
by her brother who killed both samurai
and the manager of the brothel he
carried her around town searching for
help but no one would help them as
gyutaro collapsed from exhaustion and
fatigue from his severe wounds doma who
was upper rank six at the time happened
to notice the siblings while wandering
the district in search of beautiful
girls to devour taking pity on them he
offered to help the pair by turning them
into demons claiming that it was because
he was a nice guy he then challenged
them to become strong enough to be
chosen by muzan kibutsuji and joined the
12 kizuki alongside himself the
activities of both her and her brother
eventually caught the attention of muzan
who acknowledged their strength and
power and officially allowed them to
join the 12 kazuki and both were given
the rank of upper rank 6. after she
encounters zenitsu she was dressed as
one of the girls the donkey pondered
over zenitsu's identity noting he might
be a demon slayer she later appeared
behind koinatsu seeking to eat her
before she left to be married but was
stopped by tanjiro dismissing the youth
for his weakness daki soon grew enraged
when he demanded she releases koenatsu
and attacked the demon slayer with her
sashes after she engages with tanjiro
daki was shocked when tanjido cut
through her sashes with the hinokami
kagura technique during their battle she
overpowers tanjido and nozuko jumps in
and saves him after tengen uzui san
hashida finally appeared he slashed her
head off in an instant telling her that
she's not strong enough to be upper rank
six number seven gyutaro after her
sister daki called out for him gyutaro
emerged from her body quickly taking her
to another part of the room and
reattaching her severed head tengen
attacked the pair bagyutaro quickly
countered it injuring the hashida the
mysterious demon unleashed his blood
demon art flying bloodsicles a barrage
of blood blades that failed to injure
tengen during his battle with sound
hashira yutaro was surprised by
hashida's sword skills yutaro barely
deflected one of the attacks but was
left with a slight wound to his neck he
warned tengen of his impending death
only to be surprised by the arrival of
inosuke and zenitsu the mysterious demon
reiterated his death threat believing
the arrival of the hashida's
subordinates to be insufficient he also
mentioned how he and his sister had
eaten numerous hashidas 15 and 7
respectively
closed one of his eyes and quickly
attacked tanjiro he nearly struck a blow
to the youth's neck but was thwarted by
tengen at the last second causing him to
only stab him in the chin mere inches
away from the fatal strike and proceeded
to exchange a flurry of blows with his
opponent yotaro manages to poison
hashida wounding him severely but tengan
had enough strength left to help tanjido
defeat the demon cutting his head off
while zenitsu and inosuke defeated his
sister at the same time as their heads
began to disintegrate daki screamed at
her brother blaming him for their defeat
while kyutaro retaliated that daki was
weak and had nothing to help saddened by
the siblings bickering tanjido then
stepped in covering yutero's mouth to
stop him from screaming abuse at his
sister and pleading with them to try and
get along as they only had each other
left in the world number 6. gyoko gyoko
is a demon affiliated with the 12 kizuki
holding the position of upper rank 5.
gyoko lived on the outskirts of a
fishing village near the coast and was
disliked for repeatedly collecting fish
carcasses and doing other strange things
sometimes afterward gyoko killed a
village child who came to tease him and
stuff the body in a jar
in a rage the child's parents stabbed
gyoko with a two-pronged fishing fork he
was left to die there and muzan
kibutsuji was passing by so he turned
gyoko into a demon at the swordsman's
village gyoko devoured an unsuspecting
villager and spat him right back out
stating that it wasn't edible he then
noted that destroying the swordsman's
village would severely weaken the demon
slayers when muichiro and the two
villagers came upon the shed looking for
a new sword gyoko ambushes them from a
ceramic pot once attacked by muichiro he
retreats inside his ceramic pot and
reveals he can transport himself from
pot to pot at will he explains that the
pots are his pride and artwork and
becomes very upset when they're damaged
he then summons many fish from a pot and
uses his blood demon art to attack
muichiro he traps muychito with his
blood demon art water prison pot
commenting that death by suffocation is
stylish and beautiful while muichiro
struggles to escape the water prison
gyoko advanced upon the shed he enters
and sees hotaro working on the blade
extracted from the training doll hotaro
doesn't notice gyoko's entrance behind
him enraging gyoko at the prospect of
another artist more concentrated on his
craft than he he summons a fish to
attack hotaru breaking the swordsman's
mask but not his concentration hotaru's
dedication to the blade incentivizes
gyoko to force him to break his
concentration rather than straight up
murdering him muichiro escapes from the
water prison with the help from kutetsu
surprising gyoko and causing him to
unleash octopus vaz hell muichiro's
missed breathing nick's gyoko and he
ducks back into his pot reappearing in a
different pot he argues with muichiro
about the beauty of his pots becoming
enraged after an insult to their balance
and unleashes his blood demon art after
muichiro deflects two of his attacks
gyoko reveals his true form and becomes
more serious about killing him gyoko's
true form has the ability to turn
anything he punches into fish and his
height and speed and strength muichiro
uses the misbreathing seventh form to
decapitate gyoko killing him much to his
disbelief number five kantengu as a
human handengu was known to have
committed many heinous crimes stealing
from numerous innocent people and
murdering them in various towns and
cities all while claiming that he was
innocent and it wasn't him that
committed these crimes he blamed that
his hands were solely to blame for his
actions eventually he was captured by a
high-ranked law official magistrate and
sentenced to death by decapitation
despite his outrageous claims of
innocence that were then silenced by
threatening to cut off his sinful hands
instead while imprisoned and awaiting
his execution he was approached by muzan
kibutsuji who offered to help him after
taking pity on the situation at the
swordsmiths village hantengu crawled on
the roof of a building eager to fulfill
their mission to avoid muzan's wrath he
encountered tanjiro and muichiro swiftly
avoiding an attack from the latter he
dodged a follow-up attack from tangido
only to be kicked by nezuko his head was
then severed by another attack for
muichiro causing him to regenerate into
two different demons sekido and karaku
as muichiro and tanjiro attempted to
attack these newcomers karakou blew
muichiro far into the distance with a
single wave of his uchiwa fan the two
then confronted tanjido and nizuko
briefly exchanging biting comments at
each other with sekiro then attacking
tanjiro with a burst of electricity from
his staff the two failed to notice genya
approaching them from behind with a gun
genya's shot was hit decapitating sakiro
but failing to do the same for karaku
much to the latter's amusement the young
demon slayer finished the job with his
sword but the two then turned into four
one of the new demons reminiscent of a
tengu grabbed tanjiro by the leg and
flew off with him while the other
impaled genya the former congratulated
tanjiro on figuring out their strategy
while the latter commented on genya's
weakness tanjido urged nizuko to help
genya prompting his abductor to
reprimand him for this before firing a
concussive blast of sound at the demon
slayer in the end tanjiro manages to
behead him using hinokami kagura flame
dance however the head tanjido just cut
was not the real hantengu proven as the
headless body of hantengu continues to
run away as the sun is about to rise
tanjido finally decides to continue in
pursuit he eventually locates hatangu's
real body inside of headless hantengu's
heart hantengu finally dies after having
his torso slashed by tanjiro however han
tengo managed to inform muzan about
nizuko's immunity to the sunlight
beforehand number four nakime
after hantengu's death nakime became the
new upper rank four of the twelve kizuki
when the demon slayer corps arrive at
the ubu yashiki mansion to try and stop
muzan they are all transported into the
infinity castle and separated from one
another by nakime obanai and mitsuri are
the first to encounter her but find it
extremely difficult to land blows on her
due to her control over the environment
later during the beginning of tanjido
and gyu's fight with muzan the latter
reveals that nakime has successfully
defeated both obanai and mitsuri by
crushing them both to death using the
rooms of her castle however he is taken
by surprise when the supposedly dead duo
launched a surprise attack on him still
very much alive and angrily asks nakime
what she's doing muzan is shocked upon
learning that yushiro has completely
taken control of nakime's vision and
with it the infinity castle which he
begins to use against the demon lord as
revenge for his killing of tamayo muzan
immediately begins countering yushido
using his own mental powers in order to
take back his final upper rank which
kicks off a fierce battle of wills
between the two demons this mental fight
causes the castle to completely spiral
out of control as both wrestle for
dominance and just as muzan appears to
have taken the upper hand obani and gyu
launch an attack on the demon lord he
has no choice but to counter which
causes his whole anakime to slip as he
tries to defend himself and ward the
hashidas off with his own attacks soon
realizing that he can't take pak nakime
and fight the demon slayers at the same
time muzan uses his powers to kill his
final upper rank by crushing her head
which prevents yushido from using the
castle against him and allows him to
fully focus on killing the remaining
hashiras number 3 akazan akasa is a
demon affiliated with the 12 kizuki
holding the position of upper rank 3. in
the past akaze's name was hakuji he was
born and raised in the slums to a
stickly father whom he loved deeply in
order to pay for medicine hakuji
pickpocketed from people in town but was
caught three times the magistrate beat
him and marked him with tattoos
threatening to cut off his arms the next
time he was caught and calling him a
demon child when hakuji returned home
after his third beating a villager
informed him that his father having
heard of his arrest hung himself in the
letter he left he stated he wanted
hakuji to live a full life and didn't
want to take medicine if it was earned
by dishonest means with his criminal
tattoos and no home to return to hakuji
was eventually banished from edo he
eventually met a man named keizel the
owner of a local dojo keizo then took
him in so he could nurse koyuki keisel's
sickly daughter one day keizo offered to
let hakuji take over the dojo and take
koyuki as his bride to hakuji's surprise
and embarrassment he agreed silently
vowing to protect both of them even at
the cost of his own life hakuji went to
visit his father's grave to inform him
of his marriage but quickly realized
something was amiss upon his return a
student from the dojo informed him that
the rival dojo had poisoned the well
where kuiki and keizo drank water from
the two died shortly after drinking that
water oaxakuji had been away enraged
hakuji killed all 67 members of the
rivaling dojo with his bare hands
pulverizing them to the point where
their corpses were no longer
recognizable this incident caught musang
kibutsuji's attention and though he was
disappointed to find that it had been a
human rather than a demon who'd done
such a gruesome act he decided to make
hakuji one of the 12 kizuki hakuji with
nothing left to protect and having lost
his will to live accepts and becomes the
demon akaza after transforming he lost
his memories of the time he was a human
with only a desire to become stronger
despite not knowing the reason why he
wanted to become strong akaza appears
shortly after the demon slayers have
defeated enmu and rescued the passengers
noticing a downed tanjido he immediately
rushes forward to kill him when kyojiro
stops the attack and slices his arm in
half he attempts to persuade him to
become a demon he states that as a human
he would eventually become old and die
whereas as a demon he could continue to
become more powerful akasa and kyogro
battle fiercely with tanjiro and inosuki
looking from a distance both knowing the
two are on a completely different level
of power akaze starts to make contact
with his attacks severely injuring the
hashida all of kyojiro's sword blows are
futile with the demon's rapid healing
abilities and he starts to become
desperate with multiple flame breathing
attacks akaza suddenly backs away
allowing kyojiro to catch his breath
only for tanjiro and inosuke to see him
bleeding profusely in contrast to a
completely fine and healed akaza
kyojiro's body suddenly becomes engulfed
in fire declaring he will fulfill his
duty as a hashida to the demons
confusion and wonder they hit each other
with kyojiro slicing akisa's arm torso
and almost through his neck and akasa
driving his arm through rengoku's solar
plexus the sun begins to rise and akaza
attempts to flee but is held in place by
kyojiro refusing to surrender tanjido
and inosuke attempt to aid hashira in
osuke using his beast breathing to
attack the demon akaza suddenly rips off
his own arms from kyojiro's body and
stomps the ground creating a shockwave
to knock inosuke away and give himself
the chance to flee akaza reports back to
muzan that he killed one of the hashidas
but muzan retorts it was only one
hashida and declares his desire is for
all to be dead angered at his failure
muzan takes control of akiza's cells and
causes him to bleed heavily in the
infinity castle akaza ambushes tanjiro
and giu the fight between the three
begins as akisa advances tanjido dodges
his punch and uses the hinokami kagura
on akaza and with considerable effort
severs the upper rank's arm geo enters
the fight immediately using the water
breathing akaza is instantly impressed
as it had been 50 years since he ran
into someone as good as guil after a
long battle between the three akasa
admits defeat stating that tanjid's
technique was magnificent and that he
wants to go to hell like a man he
imagines his father and keizo but when
he remembers muzan asking if he wants to
get stronger he begins to regenerate he
is stopped by koyuki thankful about
hakuji recovering his memories and
thanking him for what he had done
finally finding peace akaza
disintegrates dying as hakuji a loyal
son a protective student and a faithful
lover number two doma doma is one of the
strongest demons in 12 kazuki being the
upper rank 2. when he was a human child
because of his beautiful rainbow colored
eyes and pure white hair domo was seen
as a supernatural being since birth and
is groomed into the religious leader of
the paradise faith cult a position he
maintains to the present day at 20 years
old he met muzan kibutsuji who
transformed him into a demon at the
gathering of the upper ranks doma
questioned akaza's lack of concern for
him placing a hand on his colleague's
shoulder he expressed his worry for his
comrade safety and irritated akaza tells
doma to move his hand punching him when
he didn't immediately comply
regenerating the damage almost instantly
doma complimented his fellow upper rank
wondering if he had gotten stronger
since their last meeting soon after
muzan arrived and upper rank 2 listened
as his leader reported gyutaro's death
later inside the infinity castle as he
is consuming a group of his female
disciples doma notices shinobu at the
entrance to his room he reacts with
delight at having another meal walk
right into his room shinobu notices a
pair of sharp fans that doma uses as his
main weapon and angrily inquires if he
remembers the haudi that originally
belonged to his elder sister doma
finally remembers her by the butterfly
wing design haudi that kane once wore
and playfully expresses his
disappointment at not being able to eat
kane due to the sun rising the insect
hashira swiftly launches an attack at
him using her insect breathing to
inflict a powerful stab directly in
doma's right eyeball which impresses him
since he couldn't block it she tries to
poison him but learns that doma already
knew about her poison she is further
backed into a corner due to doma now
rapidly developing antibodies and
adjusting his body against her poison so
that after a mere five slashes and
injections of poison he is now resistant
to it entirely putting all her hopes on
injecting a large dose to kill him by
using a sick stab attack shinobu attacks
him using insect breathing and
successfully hits him however as she
attacks him he simultaneously attacks
her cutting both her collarbone and ribs
and puncturing one of her lungs shinobu
is called by doma as they fell down from
the ceiling he embraces her in a bear
hug and begins mocking her and calling
her entire attempt to defeat him a waste
of effort assuring her she will live
peacefully as a part of him and
mockingly asking her for her last words
she spitefully curses him as he begins
to kill her doma successfully kills and
eats the hashida just as her disciple
canao arrives at the scene canal enraged
launches her flower breathing at doma
which he avoids with ease smiling and
commenting on how pretty her attack is
inosuke breaks through the ceiling of
the room protecting canal from doma's
attack with his beast breathing during
the battle between doma and two demon
slayers doma's face suddenly begins to
melt he drops to the floor one of his
arms snapping off and his crystal
children begin to crack and disintegrate
as he wonders what's happening inosuke
asks if it's a trap but kano having been
informed prior to the battle of
shinobu's plan to kill doma tells him
that it isn't and that the demon is
being melted by the poison shinobu had
in her body when he consumed her as his
head falls to the floor doma thinks
about how pathetic he must be to have
lost to a poisoner like shinobu someone
who didn't even have the strength to
kill a demon by cutting its head number
one kokushibo kokushibu is by far the
strongest upper moon demon ever holding
the position of upper moon rank one over
four centuries ago kokushibu was a human
by the name of mujicatsu tsugikuni a
former demon slayer and the twin brother
of yorichitsugikuni because of yorichi's
birthmark he was doomed to be sent to
the temple and become a priest upon
turning 10 while michikatsu would become
head of the house one day while
michikatsu was practicing with sword one
of their father's men offered to give
yorichi some instruction as well though
he only showed yorichi a basic stance
the boy was able to land four blows on a
man this incident bewildered michikatsu
who had never before landed a blow and
he begged his brother to teach him a
secret as michikatsu studied the sword
he felt envious of his brother who he
felt was squandering his natural
physical talent he also feared that now
that their father likely knew about
yorichi's immense potential their roles
would be swapped and he would be the one
sent to the temple in yorichi's place
yorichi recognized this as well and left
for the temple before his father could
make him a successor his jealousy of his
brother only grew when he read his
mother's diary following her death which
revealed that yodichi had known
everything about their mother's illness
and had planned accordingly from then
michikatsu resented yorichi who he
realized to be not only physically
gifted but a genius as well he wished
for his brother's death and for the next
few years not hearing anything from him
he believed it to be true ten years
later michikatsu became a samurai and
married a woman who gave birth to two of
his children one night a demon attacked
his camp and left him the only survivor
but was quickly killed by yorichi who
came to his rescue and apologized for
not being able to save his subordinates
seeing the object of his hatred again
when twisted by jealousy michikatsu
abandoned his family and became a demon
slayer to train with yorichi frustrated
for being unable to surpass his brother
as well as fearing the fated death of
those who awaken their demon slayer
marks michikatsu was persuaded by muzan
kibutsuji and became a demon taking the
name kokushibu 60 years after becoming a
demon he came face to face with yorichi
for the last time wanting to forget his
human past he knew he had to kill his
younger brother enraged by the feeling
of inferiority he slashed yodichi's body
in half but inadvertently broke the
flute he gave him as a child seeing that
his brother still thought highly of him
even after his transformation kokushibu
couldn't help but shed a tear unable to
truly sever his bond with his brother he
decided to keep the flute for himself
inside infinity castle kokushibu
encounters missed hashira muichiro
tokito he then deduces that muichiro is
a descendant of a child he left behind
after becoming a demon the two engage in
battle but muichiro is easily defeated
by kokushibu who offers him to become a
demon this discussion is however
interrupted by genya shooting his
nichiren gun kokushibu effortlessly
avoids the gunshot appearing behind
genya and then proceeding to cut off
both his arms and his torso in half as
he goes to finish him off genya's older
brother sanemi appears stopping the
upper moon sanemi and kokushibu then
begin their intense duel with kokushibu
being slightly taken aback at the skill
of the win hashira after some struggling
kokushibu shows glee at the opportunity
to fight such a skilled hashida he was
about to deal a finishing to sanemi but
was stopped by the arrival of gyome the
stone hashira kokoshibo was unable to
retain himself openly stating that he
admired gyome's physical form following
an intense back and forth battle
guilleme reveals his trump card he meant
to save from muzan his demon slayer mark
the battle then begins to pick up
kokushibo's attacks increase with both
intensity and frequency he is able to
sever two of sanemi's fingers and both
demon slayers are reduced to putting all
of their efforts into simply avoiding
his attacks right as it seemed that
sanemy is about to lose muichiro rejoins
the battle saving the other hashida just
in time with the combined force of three
hashidas they finally managed to defeat
kokushibu for good
if you're interested in more demon
slayer content click on this video where
we explain all former and current
hashida